[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF HOFFMAN: It's an exciting
time, the last few minutes
before launch, as the
shuttle really comes alive,
and then all of a sudden you
get this big kick in the pants,
and you look out the
window, and there's
the ground falling away,
and everything is shaking.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're heading back into space.
JEFF HOFFMAN: My best
friend from the second grade
after I became an astronaut--
he said to me, Jeff,
this is incredible.
I used to play
spaceman with you,
and now you're actually
going up into space.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen,
and with us this week is
Professor Jeff Hoffman,
a former NASA astronaut.
Over the course
of five missions,
he's logged over
1,000 hours in space--
and yep, some of those
do include spacewalks.
Professor Hoffman teaches
Aeronautics and Astronautics
at MIT, but he's also
committed to unlocking
this knowledge for the world.
He's shared course 16.00,
Introduction to Aerospace
Engineering, on
MITx, and 16.885,
Engineering the Space Shuttle,
which can be found on MITx
and OCW.
One of the things I loved about
my conversation with Professor
Hoffman was his
take on perspective,
and how a grander-scale view--
like, say, from outer space--
can dramatically shift the
way we live here on Earth.
JEFF HOFFMAN: We fly
so much in airplanes,
and probably most
people don't remember
the first time they look
out of an airplane window
and see the Earth.
I mean, it's a completely
different perspective
that you get.
And now rockets
and space travel,
which allow us to
go even farther
and to try to give people
the perspective of looking
at the Earth from space--
is very important.
I mean, I was an astronomer.
I know the Earth is a planet.
I mean, give me a break.
But nevertheless, when
you actually see it
from the perspective
of being in space--
I mean, imagine you
go up into space
and you look at this thin,
blue line on the horizon, which
is the Earth's atmosphere.
I mean, you go out
here from the surface
of the Earth on a clear
day in the big blue sky,
and it looks like
it goes on forever.
And unfortunately, that
gives many people the idea
that it doesn't matter what
you put into the atmosphere,
because it's so big
that it can absorb it.
And it's the same
thing with the oceans.
And when you finally
get that gut feeling
of the finiteness of the Earth--
the oceans, the atmosphere--
and you realize we live
in a closed system,
that the Earth is
a finite system--
that makes a difference, because
exponential growth cannot
continue forever
in a closed system.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor
Hoffman's first expedition
into space was in 1985.
Before that, he was actually
doing work here at MIT,
launching telescopes into space.
Long before that,
though, like many kids
since the second half
of the 20th century,
he wanted to go
to space himself.
JEFF HOFFMAN: When
I was a little kid,
I used to love looking
up at the stars.
Of course, early part of my
life we lived in New York City,
and more often, it
would be looking up
at the stars in the planetarium.
But I was fascinated with that.
And it was the dawn
of the Space Age,
and there were lots of articles
in newspapers, magazines,
television shows about the
coming of the Space Age.
And I ended up--
in fact, my best friend
from the second grade,
after I became an astronaut--
he said to me, you know,
Jeff, this is incredible.
I used to play
spaceman with you,
and now you're actually
going up into space.
It was a combination of the
fascination with how far
away things were, and the
fact that by going up,
you got a completely
new view of things.
And also that space travel
represented the future,
and I found that
really exciting.
So then when the first
astronauts started to fly,
they were our heroes,
and I just wanted
to go up there and look down.
Unfortunately, I soon realized
that all the astronauts
were military pilots, and that
was not really a career for me.
But that desire to look further
out, to understand what's
above, what's out there--
that remained with me, and
so I ended up with a degree--
advanced degrees
in astrophysics.
And I was launching
telescopes to look at X-rays--
and you have to go above the
atmosphere to look at X-rays.
That's what I was
doing here at MIT.
Then NASA started to
develop what was then
the brand new Space Shuttle.
Now we're up to the late '70s,
and the thing about the Shuttle
was they had a crew of
seven, and they only
needed two pilots.
So that was great,
because that's
what really opened
things up for scientists,
engineers, medical doctors, and
that's what gave me my chance.
And I applied for it, and was
lucky enough to get selected.
And so then I could get the
real overview from space.
SARAH HANSEN: Five
missions later,
and Professor Hoffman
is back on Earth.
And since 2001,
he's been teaching
a series of courses
on aeronautics
and engineering here at MIT.
Luckily for us,
Professor Hoffman
infuses much of his NASA
experiences and learnings
into his courses.
To help the students really
understand the big picture--
like he had to at NASA--
he emphasizes the concept
of systems engineering.
Understanding
systems engineering
helps students and
astronauts alike
to tackle complex
problems, and it all
starts by looking at
the bigger picture.
JEFF HOFFMAN:
Particularly anything
having to do with space, with
complex systems in general.
We try to teach systems
engineering here.
You have to have the
big picture if you're
going to be able to manage
a complex engineering
or scientific project.
In the AeroAstro
Department at MIT,
we don't really teach
systems engineering
as a specific subject until the
graduate level, because really,
if you're going to be a
professional systems engineer
and be good at it,
you really need
a background in some of
the basics of engineering.
So just like at
NASA Mission Control
you don't start out
being a flight director.
You start out working in one
of the individual disciplines.
And usually, the most
successful flight directors
have worked in at
least two disciplines.
And then you understand how a
disciplined engineer approaches
a problem, and then you
can be more useful trying
to get the big view of things.
SARAH HANSEN: Another
really wonderful part
of Professor Hoffman's courses
is how they combine theory
with real hands-on experience.
JEFF HOFFMAN: The
majority of our students--
they are going to be
working engineers.
They're going to go
out into the world.
Many of them get jobs
in aerospace companies,
and they're going to build
the next generation of space
vehicles.
And we want them to have
had some experience actually
building something.
For instance, here, I teach the
freshman course in introduction
to aerospace engineering
and human spaceflight,
and we have the students
build a project--
a lighter-than-air vehicle.
We give them the material.
We give them some radio
control equipment,
motors, servos, propellers,
and lead them through,
in a systems engineering way
of going about the project,
without formally telling
them that they're
practicing systems engineering.
I mean, even if you're going
to be a disciplined engineer
and just concentrate on
one aspect of a system,
it still helps to have
the concept that somehow
all these systems
have to play together.
SARAH HANSEN: Another way
Professor Hoffman ensures
that these ideas really sink in
is with something called CDIO.
CDIO stands for Conceive,
Design, Implement, and Operate,
and it's a learning
tool that helps students
to think through a problem "from
soup to nuts," as he puts it.
What's wonderful about
it-- beyond the fact that
it's helped us put humans
into space and on the moon--
is that it can be useful in
tons of different contexts,
even beyond engineering.
JEFF HOFFMAN: The bottom line,
and the moral of all of this
is you really need,
from the very beginning,
when you're designing a system,
to think about the end user.
Very often, the people
who design it never
have to use the system.
They come up with a design, and
they throw it over the fence,
and somebody else builds it.
And they don't have to use it,
they throw it over the fence,
and then the end
user takes over.
And so it's really critical.
So the CDIO-- it's
a way of approaching
engineering particularly
complex systems
that, from the
very beginning, you
take into account all of
those phases of an engineering
system.
I mean, it's not just
engineering systems.
When you build a house, I
mean, you better figure out
what it's going to be
to live in this house
before it gets built.
Otherwise you're
going to have a lot of bills
with a contractor to make
changes at the last minute.
And that's one of
the other things
you learn, and one of the
basic principles of systems
engineering-- and particularly
in the space business--
is that the further you
get into the implementation
of the system,
the more expensive
it is to make any changes.
SARAH HANSEN: I
feel like that's one
of the beauties of this course.
You might be working in
a completely different
discipline, but you can
find something useful.
JEFF HOFFMAN: That is
kind of the subtext
of the course-- is it's not
just about the Space Shuttle.
It's learning how a very, very
complex system was initially
conceived, designed,
implemented, and operated.
And that's why, after
the central part
of the course, where we
talk about the design
and building of all these
complex subsystems, then
we brought in people who
actually operated the shuttle--
the launch director, the flight
director, the payload operator,
an astronaut pilot
who flew the shuttle,
and so on-- because that's the
final phase of the whole CDIO.
As I say, from
soup to nuts, this
is what the shuttle
was all about.
SARAH HANSEN: To really
understand the development
of the space program
here in the US,
it helps to look at the
interconnected series
of systems that built it.
And they go well beyond
engineering and mathematics.
For example, politics
played a huge role
in aerospace engineering.
JEFF HOFFMAN: We
really thought it
was important to
devote the beginning
lectures of the course to what
were all these influences which
had such an important
impact on the design?
Economically, it was no
longer possible to treat
NASA in such a special way
as had been done by Apollo.
I mean, 400,000 people working
on Apollo at the height of it,
4% of the federal budget
going to space exploration--
this is not normal
for space activities.
It was a very special
time in our history.
Then you get to the late '60s.
I mean, even John Kennedy, after
having made this commitment
to go to the moon, started to
have second thoughts about how
much it was going to cost.
Then, of course, he
was assassinated,
and getting to the moon
by the end of the decade
sort of became our way of
honoring Kennedy's legacy.
So it wasn't a question.
We did it.
But along came the
Nixon administration
following President Johnson's
Great Society program--
huge increase in
social spending--
and then the Vietnam War.
And space-- it was clear, and
Nixon was explicit about this--
the space program has
to take its proper role
among all other
national priorities,
and that really involved a
huge decrease in NASA's budget.
And the people running
NASA saw that coming.
And so how do you
continue to explore space?
They were faced with
the real possibility
that human space flight in this
country might come to an end.
And NASA realized--
quite correctly--
that reusability was a key.
But then you get into all of
the social, economic, political
influences that put a lot of
very, very tight requirements
on the shuttle--
particularly since, in order
to justify the expense,
NASA basically
sold the shuttle as
capable of doing anything
we needed to do in space,
we could do with a shuttle.
We used it for
scientific experiments.
We used it to launch satellites.
We used it to test out
new engineering systems.
We used it to repair satellites
like the Hubble Space
Telescope.
We used it to build the
International Space Station.
For me, all my flights were in
the space shuttle, so I look
on it with a great fondness--
recognizing its
limitations, but also
understanding the
incredible things
that it allowed
us to accomplish.
SARAH HANSEN: While
Professor Hoffman's classes
offer incredible insights into
what he's learned at NASA--
not to mention some
deeply important skills
for any student or
intrigued OCW user--
it's not every day that I get to
sit down with a real astronaut.
So of course I had to ask
him what it was all like--
being launched into space, being
in orbit, doing a spacewalk.
JEFF HOFFMAN: Before
my first launch,
I asked many of the astronauts
who had already flown,
what's it going to be like?
They put us in simulators,
and they shake the simulator
a little bit, but
they said, forget it.
That's nothing like
the real thing.
It's hard to prepare yourself.
It's an exciting time, the
last few minutes before launch,
as the shuttle
really comes alive,
and then all of a sudden you
get this big kick in the pants,
and you look out the
window, and there's
the ground falling away,
and everything is shaking,
and tremendous noise.
People told me that
there was going
to be more vibration than
I could ever imagine,
and they were right, because
I couldn't imagine it.
45 seconds later, you're
going straight up,
and you break the sound barrier.
And that gives you
even more vibration,
because you get all
of these shock waves.
And I remember
thinking to myself,
no, this can't be normal.
The wings are going to fall off.
Something's wrong.
But I mean, the
structural engineers
knew what they were
doing, and the wings
did not fall off-- or else
I wouldn't be here talking
with you.
With the Shuttle, it was those
two big, solid rocket boosters
that caused all
of the vibration,
and they burn for
the first 2 minutes.
Once they fall off, it's
a really smooth ride.
I mean, everybody then talks
about it's an electric ride
all the way up into orbit.
So that contrast between
the extreme vibration
of riding on the side of
a solid rocket booster,
and then just the burning of
the hydrogen-oxygen engines
was really quite extraordinary.
SARAH HANSEN: Did anyone
ever just get really scared
right before lift off?
JEFF HOFFMAN: There
are some astronauts
who will tell you they
don't like launches
because of the risk involved.
For me-- I mean, I remember,
before the first flight,
riding out to the launch
pad and looking up
at this incredible vehicle
that I'm going to get in
and thinking to
myself, first of all,
this is not the time
to be asking yourself
if you really want to do this.
But then what was really
going through my mind
is ever since I
was six years old
and I saw Flash Gordon take off
in his rocket ship in science
fiction, and I always
dreamed of doing it,
and I'm about to
leave the planet--
it was exciting.
I mean, so my idea was sit
back and enjoy the ride.
I'm not a pilot, so I
didn't have to even worry
about flying the shuttle.
I could just look out
the window and enjoy
this incredible experience--
which it certainly was.
Then all of a sudden, you
feel yourself floating up
in your seat.
You're weightless.
I remember unstrapping and
floating over to the window,
and there was the coast of
Africa coming over the horizon,
and that's when
it really hit me.
Oh, my God.
I'm in space!
SARAH HANSEN: While
launching into space
is certainly an incredible
ride, Professor Hoffman
also did a number of
spacewalks during his career.
He shared with us the
story of one of them.
JEFF HOFFMAN: I remember
my very first spacewalk
on my first space flight.
I went out, and we had to
attach some special tools
to the end of the robotic
arm as part of an attempt
to rescue a satellite
which had been deployed
but didn't turn on.
And then we had been out
for about two hours or so,
and the sun set, and then they
didn't have the right lighting
conditions.
And I'll never forget the call
that came up from the ground--
hey, Jeff and Dave, would
you mind staying outside
for another 45 minutes while
we wait for the sun to come--
SARAH HANSEN: Oh, my gosh!
JEFF HOFFMAN: And I
had nothing to do.
I was just-- I mean, I was
a tourist out in a spacesuit
holding on.
I thought to myself, I'm
just going to have some fun.
So actually, I was sort of
crawling all over the shuttle.
And thinking back, I
crawled halfway up the tail,
and the commander told
me he was doing his best
to keep the TV cameras off me.
I mean, I was so ecstatic.
I was thinking about the
fact that maybe some people
on the ground
wouldn't want to see
an astronaut hanging from
the tail of the shuttle,
but I did it.
SARAH HANSEN: It's all
a matter of perspective.
To broaden your own
horizons from the safety
of your own home, be sure to
check out Professor Hoffman's
course materials on
MIT OpenCourseWare,
or on the MIT Open
Learning library.
Thanks so much for listening.
Your comments have inspired
me to keep learning.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
AUDIO BUMPER: Ma, park the car.